now i'm going to
go through some questions here so again
i apologize i know this is a long
session but um you know there's a lot of
questions here that's come up but i do
want to get to as much as we can
gary i went over max and min delta okay
um again max delta
just really quick for those that came in
late
max delta there's delta max delta min
delta
the headline number delta's what delta
was when the bar closed
or as the bar is forming now max delta
min delta is how strong delta was in a
bar's max delta so you can see like this
bar says 631
that's how strong delta was in the bar
down here
min delta is minus 48 okay so that just
tells you that
there's very little aggressive selling
at one point in the bar now there's
aggressive selling in the bar
of course but it never turned it turned
negative here so you can see it turned
negative but just 48 so it was there for
a very short time now there's
there's times let me find a bar here
where here
so this bar it's zero min delta so at no
point in this bar
now even though there's aggressive
selling was it enough to turn the delta
negative so it's at zero
right and we closed the delta in 1969
the max delta closed at 1970. so we
closed right near our max delta
now over here this red bar
final delta is minus a thousand min
delta is minus 1062
max delta zero so even though there's
aggressive buying at no point where the
aggressive buyers
in control so to speak of this bar and
we close
our delta right near our min delta so
you know it's telling me this bar is
very strong selling
right just as this bar with the
min delta zero and the max delta of 1970
and the final delta 1969 is telling me
that this bar is very strong aggressive
buying
okay um
yeah i try to use it with nq it's hard
to do it is you know enqueues is not a
market for
people that are new to trading or new to
or
under order flow in general okay it's a
tough market
because it's very volatile and you know
this is
nq right this is a you know let's take a
look
during the day session on on friday
right and got to scrunch it up because
it's so hard to read
but people
can't handle this volatility look at
this bar it doesn't look like much but
it's actually covering
you know 85 and a half all the way up to
0809 08 and a half we'll call it
so that's what over that's a 23-point
move in that one bar
you know here's a bar we went from 32
all the way up to 66 you know that's a
30-point move in a bar
it's not a market for everybody to
to trade right because you just can't um
there's plenty of other markets that you
can trade that
has normal price activity
okay speaking of point of control in
your opinion do you think there's value
in tracking
like like a moving average no i don't
you know you daniel you could use v-wap
or
you know a moving average you know we
did
i i did have someone programmed that up
for me but honestly
i i didn't find much value in it um i
think you're better off
using value or v web
um than a moving average of points of
control
because points of control again
there's times where points of control
just
can be at one level in a bar versus
another level in a bar by just a few
contracts
right and that's obviously just going to
throw it off a bit but i i didn't find
any
value in tracking it but that that's me
um pam asks i have an older version of
overflows trader
can i get it the upgrade yeah you just
gotta send me an email pam
i watched one of your earlier
presentations you're discussing delta
candles
um yeah daniel they are available
but if you have a paid version of
ninjatrader
they have them on the paid version of
ninjatrader i forgot what they're called
so their delta tool or something if you
have the
100 the with the 1200 version of
ninjatrader
my software will work on the free
version of ninjatrader
okay um so you know because i have a lot
of users that are
in countries you know foreign countries
not the united states
that trade you know like i got customers
in malaysia that trade the malaysia
contracts
i got customers in china that shade the
the chinese stock market
using order flow they use the free
version of ninjatrader they get my
software they have a data feed
for those local markets okay
donald asks can you talk about your
99 videos you know i had a new course
that came out it was called the um
next level order flow that's just yeah
it's a simple
12 module course on or i'll say simple
because it's
sort of advanced concepts of order flow
analysis that
you know it really you know order flows
is
it's constantly honestly changing but
there's always
i like to say new developments sort of
in order flow because you know as
more people start to look at order flow
people start
understanding really what's happening in
the market better
and you know that's why i have this next
level order flow courses to help you
understand
sort of the the new newer things in in
order for example you go look
there's a lot of people teaching
overflow but they're just teaching stuff
from 10 years ago
right i mean we're so i like i don't say
i'm so far advanced but
you know the knowledge of order flow
over the last just five years
has jumped a lot right as more people
understand the
the different data points that's
available in the order flow
um quinjin asks yeah if you have the
original order flows trader
you get the upgrade for free just shoot
me an email que jen um i'll take a look
at your email
and send you over a link but um in the
meantime you can always just shoot me an
email
what is the best minimum requirement to
run a tick replay function
honestly i've got several computers
that i use for testing and stuff as well
as trading
my trading is an i7 with
a one terabyte ssd
and i think just 16 gigs
of ram but i have testing machines i use
just an i5 with
you know honestly you can buy computers
for quite cheap now i've got an
i got a couple i5s with one with 16 one
with 32 gig
ram and you know whatever 512 ssd
on those so again you don't need you
know to get spend
five thousand dollars on a trading
computer you know
it's nice but for what um
yes the webinar is recorded um
how would delta be displayed by
different time frames well again
it's going to depend on
your chart you know so if you look at a
one minute chart it's going to show you
the delta for that
one minute bar if you're looking at a
five minute bar it's going to show you
the delta for that five minute period
if you're looking at a 15 minute chart
it's going to show you the delta for
that 15 minute period
okay if you're looking at a four range
chart for that
bar with the four ranges is going to
show you the delta for that
um yep there will be a replay
no i don't have it for tradestation
actually i heard something quite scary
with tradestation uh mark minervi
if you guys are familiar with him he's
initiated a almost a million dollar wire
transfer out of trade station like 998
thousand dollars
and never hit his bank and he called up
tradestation sort of
you know ask about it and well there's
nothing we can do you know so
i've been hearing a lot of people
actually moving away from tradestation
lately but again you know that's
that was just a story i heard
online um yes they'll be recorded
okay a lot of people's yeah i understand
yeah it's saturday morning i know a lot
of us have lives
but again i want to talk a bit about um
you know the software someone asked me
to explain about absorption
um
the absorption it would be a really
another
one hours um to take it up i i have a
course on absorption actually but um
you know it's just really quick you know
absorption you're looking for
a market you know you're looking for
passive buyers or passive sellers to be
coming into the market
um that's really the main thing you want
to
you want to look at humphrey do you
incorporate
srt lines i'm not sure what srt lines
are
um question about what
order flows in longer timeframes
honestly i don't look beyond i do have a
15 minute chart
but i don't look beyond 15 minutes i do
watch a five minute chart
fairly frequently during the day but
again i trade on one minute and 30
second charts
honestly you know it's kind of honestly
it's not worth
looking at 15 15-minute charts but
when you're you're analyzing order flow
you're analyzing what's happening right
now
okay and you don't want to wait 15
minutes sort of to
take action or 10 minutes or something
or five minutes
so to speak you know when you see
something happening in the order flow
that's when it's going to be most um
right for opportunity right not after
oh i see something now then you imagine
you wait for
10 minutes for confirmation you know
it's probably over by then
um yes nick
asks about uh 2.0 to 3.0
yeah yeah i sent everybody and actually
in the email back in
october when we released it so you
actually probably have it already
you know on the your email um yeah but
again you know i know some people you
know get busy they stop training for a
while and
they sort of disregard my emails but
again yeah any anybody that it's got 2.0
you want to upgrade to 3.0 just shoot me
an email but again i'll send out an
email again
for people trevor yeah there will be a
recording available um i still need to
edit it but uh deal with it
um do you use unfinished business when
you trade no i don't
i sort of explained why it i i just i
just find the market's too volatile
really nowadays too
it's not really the way it was designed
to use i mean
most of the time 95 percent of time
unfinished business gets corrected
within the next bar
or two usually immediately in the next
bar
but i i don't use it anymore i looked at
it for
several years earlier you know back in
2014 2015 but
yeah it's just something that i didn't
really find um useful much
in my trading way i trade early thursday
morning before the cash opened the
market was slowly going up the
cumulative delta was
going down how would you interpret that
should commutative delta always
correlate with the overall trend in the
market
um generally yes but no
and
the reason being okay you have to
understand
cumulative delta is it's cumulative for
the day
so you know let me see
i'm not sure nasdaq let's find a market
here it's a bit better
talk about it um
well okay yes but e-minis um thursday
morning
thursday what date was thursday the
fourth before the cash open what day
since the fifth
fourth
okay so you know we're still negative
here right
now you can see this red line down here
at the bottom
okay and he's saying
cumulative delta was slowly the market
was slowly going up he with the delta
was going down
now granted before the cash market opens
you got a lot less volume
okay and so that's going to have an
effect on the market
okay so because when you're looking at
cumulative delta
right and you see here right
kill it to delta is only 600 500
300 and you get a bar that's got a
volume of a thousand
right well this thousand is going to
wreak havoc on your
cumulative delta right now once you get
into the trading day
then it's really going to you know sort
of
reassert itself now here this market is
mostly going sideways
cumulative deltas is kind of getting
strong actually so it was coming down
you got negative cumulative delta turns
negative and it goes positive 357
139 844 1233.
it's just going sideways now normally
right you're seeing the rising
cumulative delta
right you you're expecting this market
to start rallying right and
it's not so then it gets whacked here
right you got a thousand
negative delta so it goes down to 277
and it goes back positive 981 back to
1200 then you're getting these small
deltas 29 149
58 and it gets whacked here
big buying right 2 000 right look at
this
cumulative delta here so we're at
positive 2 000 now
earlier we're at you know at that same
level here
right this high of this bar correlates
to this bar it's at minus thirteen
hundred
okay but the market's not moving
anywhere
okay so you got to be asking those
questions is okay yeah positive delta
delta is increasing all right he's
getting stronger or plus 2 000 but we're
still
you know going sideways right is that a
good sign or
a bad sign what do you think well
obviously this delta jumped from 900 to
2000 here because this bar's got 1100
positive delta
but if you're seeing delta expand right
cumulative delta expanding and the
market's not going anywhere
not a good sign obviously right because
you should be going higher
right and it's not it's just still going
sideways because every time you start
putting in some nice positive delta it
gets whacked right a thousand here
right you get up to 1400 gets sold here
another 500
right by a thousand boom it gets sold
700 694. okay so you're back down to
all right and it's more selling 460
659 now it's going down right it's still
positive delta
okay well you know at this point
you know you're seeing well you got some
selling got some small buying
these deltas are small now for me i have
a rule that when i see delta around
50 it's small but obviously on a
markets that trade a lot of volume in
this case you're trading nine thousand
six thousand eight thousand
i consider 140 to be you know
less than anything less than 150 on a
heavy volume to be kind of neutral right
you know if it starts getting above 3
400 then
it's starting to give me some direction
but when i start seeing small deltas
123 140 107 164.
i'm viewing that as kind of neutral okay
now
excuse me so this delta is just sort of
hanging around here just sort of going
back and forth right but now i start to
see it pick up
right again a thousand back up to a
thousand because here's just you know
sub a thousand two hundred three hundred
four hundred three hundred
now it's back to a thousand a thousand
i'm starting to look for
this market to move higher because you
know we're going down we got cumulative
deltas
are growing so there's buying coming in
right there's buying coming in
but every time it it sort of starts to
move higher wham it gets sold
okay i would buy it you know in here
okay boom i get stopped out i'd be
looking to buy it again here
right as we start to move higher the
value gaps here you got a value gap
higher right i'd be looking to buy it in
this bar
then i get stopped out okay fine you
know again it's not
about trying to pick the low of the day
it's about letting the market tell you
hey you know what we're coming down but
every we've still got that
nice aggressive buying coming in right i
mean it's not going to keep going down
down down with
a negative and positive the cumulative
delta is going to keep growing
right because there's strength there's
buying but every time it starts to turn
around it gets whacked
right you see the delta 1000 right 600
but there is buying coming in right but
that buying is not being sustained
finally it gets sustained here
right and this is why i like the value
areas right because i see
i got a gap in value here right that's a
good sign when i'm looking to get long
if i see the next bar of gaps
in the value yeah i can get long okay
fine i got stopped out here
it's not the end of the world i'm still
waiting for
you know a trigger so to speak they'd be
getting long in here
again okay i see the aggressive buying
starting to come in 645 460.
i got the value area gap i get long
again 80
3800 now it's off to the races right all
the way back up to 38 20.
okay so hopefully that james will answer
your question there um
yes it's recorded i'm trading in queue
and
mnq problem is with huge money how can i
use your software in right way to see
most things peter asks
it's
well it really depends on your time
frame um honestly you know
you got to be trading in a time frame
especially in mnq or in queue that
it's manageable right it's
you're looking at 30 40 point moves in
one minute
it's going to be it's not manageable
honestly
right now with when volatility is high
nasdaq it's difficult for everybody to
trade
right now you know there's people are
crushing it in nasdaq
because they are honestly more
experienced but they understand it right
that with the increased volatility
obviously comes
increased price ranges right because you
know when you got volatility really
what's happening
right markets got to that's why you get
expanded bars
is because you know the price has to
cover more ground to find balance
right that's why you're getting price
ranges in nq
recently you know of 30 points 40 points
it's because it's it can't find balance
right there's just very little
volume in there honestly um they said
it's not a market for everybody to
to trade and again there's nobody
putting a gun to your head saying oh you
gotta trade nasdaq now i know a lot of
people are interested in nasdaq
simply because they see a lot of other
people
pulling out buckets of money
you know and honestly sometimes i'm a
bit jealous you know i wish i had that
temperament to trade nasdaq but it's
just too volatile even for me
um to trade it and trust me i've traded
in many i've traded during the
long-term credit management crash
obviously i traded in
well i got started around the times when
interest rates started rising
in the 90s but you know bearings
you know i remember it came in that
night when bearings was
was uh when nick gleason you know all
that stuff came
came out and that with nick gleason
president of
frickin dean witter is there or dean
with her futures
rather he's there in the office it's a
sunday night
and the phones you know things were
going berserk
and there's the president of dean
witters like trying to calm the
customers down
tell everybody you know things will be
fine you know
it's the financial system the safe and
all that stuff and
it's funny because guys he's an old
floor guy he's an old board of trade
guys a great guy
larry mullner but laughing because
he's like trying to right order you know
write you know
tickets tickets up you know like his
buys and sells
he didn't have a pencil or a pen rather
he's using a highlighter
you know i know the old days the tickets
used to be carbon copies
it's just laughing but you know i plus
this thing i use he is an old
board of trade guy and he was a monster
on the board of trade um
he was like buddies with john henry
before john henry got started
but um yeah you know not
every market is is for everybody now
james is going to ask about
come with the delta yeah you know it
resets at the trading day so you can see
here
um this is the end of the trading day
right here we start the new trading day
so
it ended cumulative delta mine the day
before minus 3 300
then it starts at -181 it doesn't start
at midnight it starts on the trading day
yes uh michael confirmation is key in
anything
whether in trading or in life right
you're not gonna go on a second date if
the girl is giving you
bad vibes on the first date um
john stern asks yes to run yes this is
recorded
and i'll be sending out guys emails
we're probably pointing control what is
the check delta feature
yeah you know um check delta
my programmer wanted to put that in um
i think he put it in because a user was
messaging him directly about it
and basically what it's going to do
check delta is
so for a bearish signal if you're going
to enable the check
each one has a check delta so for a
bearish prominent point of control you
would have to have negative delta for
bullish primary point of control would
have to have positive delta
okay so it's just one extra layer of
confirmation
um i personally i don't i don't use it
but it was it was a user request
that got put in there
in volatile days like we had this week
in the es do you have a preference
between time based and range based
charts no
um i used to trade a lot of range based
charts when the markets were more
you know back in 2015 16 when markets
were
more stable now with this volatility
you know if you're looking at a range
based chart and forget about it
in in some markets unless you're using a
big range like
in queue if you're using 20 points but
you know if you're using
s ps i used to use a four range chart in
an eight range chart
but and the reason i use the four range
and eight range charts those were days
when we would have a
a 15 20 point range would be considered
big
a lot of days would have ranges of 10
points so
i would use four points a four tick
chart
five four range chart on normal days but
if i notice volatility was picking up i
would switch to an eight range
you know and profit targets are gonna be
different so on a four point range
chart i'm going to have smaller profit
targets on an eight range
chart i'm gonna have bigger i would use
five on an eight and
two two and a half on on a four range
chart but again that was
different trading environments that were
in now
obviously now the markets are
um i don't know how you describe it
they're different it's a different
market condition
you know eventually hopefully markets
will um
you know sort of calm down and get back
to normal conditions but again you know
that's the equities you know if you're
trading in other markets
then um you know
you don't always you need to get the
price moves you know if you're looking
at grains grains are normal
for the most part unless there's a uh
wasde report right the supply and demand
report
um you know you look at some of these
other markets
they're pretty normal right but it's the
equities marcus said obviously
everyone's attracted to because you turn
on the tv
dao is down two percent you know over up
this amount etc so
again it's going to depend um
on what you want to look at so ratios in
nasdaq i use the same ratios
whether it's nasdaq whether it's bonds
whether it's
e-minis i don't change the ratios
at all you know i use the same ratios no
it's not available for sierra um
you know there's a soft you know sierra
has a footprint for free
um and there's add-ons you can get for
it but
um uh
i won't get into it but um you know
there are people that
have my tools on sierra that
i don't get paid for basically anymore
um
you know people would ask sierra to add
certain things on like the ratios
but again you know what's the point of
having these tools if you don't know how
to use them
all right you could add you know like i
said you can look up here right
ninjatrader got
whatever 300 different indicators under
the indicator setting
right you pull up um here looking look
at all this stuff right
nobody uses that all right but oh you
know hey let's add some more indicators
in there
all right hey let's add the relative
vigor index oh that's great yeah yeah i
got that this has
said this price oscillator let's add
this
um you know what do you want to call it
some
swing team uh you know it's just adding
stuff
you know put it on their sales page oh
yeah we've got 300 indicators the stuff
that's
in the order for trader software is
stuff that's
being used now sort of coming back to
using a range based chart right one of
the versus the time based chart
on a volatile market you know you can
get price swings
you get one two three four five six
seven
eight bars in one minute on a four range
chart whereas on the
one minute chart it would be one bar you
know you could even get
more you know this is look at this move
here
okay this is 257 and 37 seconds
one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten
eleven bars this is a move from 38 all
the way down to 46 unless you're
you know an algo you know or a human
robot
you're not going to catch this move
right because you're too slow
right i just find using non-volatile
markets range
time-based charts a bit easier to
understand
jeff asks my trade with es
as a scalper what time frame would you
use again it really depends on
on you um i used i've gone down to 30
seconds um
again you're dealing with tick and and
range again like like i just explained
here
you can find some good training oh this
is a great short here right
like this right yeah this is a great
short right i got a prominent point of
control well
yeah you get short okay then you get
stopped out and then oh i got another
one
up here it's a great one i get short but
by the time i get short the markets move
four points already right that's the
problem with range based charts whereas
at least on
you know on a 30-second chart
you know i just find it a bit more
manageable for myself
excuse me um okay get near the end here
some questions
uh would it be sending out recording yep
can i use this in 4x
yes you can um
i don't have forex data here but you can
the
you know honestly it's better to use the
cme
currency contracts honestly you know
it's
i would say forex brokers are dodgy but
honestly
i i i got a lot of people that use
the software look at the cme
contracts um the data
that's coming in over the you know for
the 6e right zero currency 6j for japan
use that data use it with the order flow
and then they just trade
through their forex broker
um yeah my software is not
this order flows trader software the
footprint is not compatible with
bloodhound
i don't think it will ever be because
what bloodhound reads and what's in the
actual order flow
we literally have to break out all those
different pieces of analysis
as as separate indicators for it to work
on bloodhounds
stefan asked about the 2.0 the 3.0
upgrade
there's no discounts because it's free
you don't have to pay extra for it
richard again just shoot me an email
right if you upgrade your computer you
know if you
upgrade your computer or you even do a
windows
bios upgrade and you load ninjatrader
again
it's going to give you a new machine id
and so you'll need a new license so
basically
just let me know that you've changed
your lice your
computer or you changed your you know
you did a windows upgrade
and the ninjatrader is giving you a
different machine id just shoot me an
email
because the way the license works it
works per computer and it's tied to
that machine id
excuse me let me drink some water here
um oh we're going on almost three hours
so
you know anytime there's like a big
change like that on you on your
motherboard or whatever
um just let me know chris asks
i'm looking to use this for forex for
technical analysis at swing levels you
know
one of my first users right one of my
biggest supporters of the software
he i don't say he's a swing trader but
he
trades at pivot levels
right he's got his p he's got his levels
right he knows what they are
and really what he's looking for is what
happens in the order flow
at those levels so for example say
you know say this is his level right
here okay we'll just call it you know
here
market comes down trades below and
you'll see oh you know i've got
price rejection down here you know i've
got price
exhaustion as well then we start coming
back up
through his level you know he's willing
to you know those are the trades that he
likes to see
you know obviously it'd be better if the
market came right you know if his
level is like right here or something or
his level is here
you know one tick or two ticks away and
then you start seeing price rejection or
something
he gets all excited right those are the
trades he loves to take but
again you know there's so many different
ways so many different tools that we
have in the order flows trader software
um that you could use it yeah negative
comments competition
yeah you know it is what it is you know
again it's like
people sometimes you know it's like yeah
i got negative comments about mcdonald's
sometimes right they got no
go there to buy a happy meal for my kids
okay yeah we've got no toys
okay great now it is what it is um
that's all now one of those converts
mike um
yeah yeah thanks daniel um it's nice to
hear that you know
that is that has helped your trading
really i mean that's really what it's
about is it's about helping people
um in it no i don't have a live trading
room anymore i do
my kids are at home all day with their
school so
honestly it's hard even for me trading
during the day
um because my son is in first grade is
he's just right at the end of my desk
he's got his own little desk with his
homeschooling
stuff and his teacher sends us stuff
we gotta print this up she'll send us
all the 20 pdfs to print up and then she
won't tell you which one she's using
today
then she'll be like oh just pull this
page out okay let's get started it's
like what you
know which page so you know sometimes i
find myself i'm trying to trade
and deal with that so that's why i can't
have a trading room when my kids go back
in school
um you know
i don't necessarily have a trading room
i'd rather just stream it live for
everybody
you know there's no point in charging
for that um what's the preferred time or
range again
but it's there's no preferred time or
range it depends on you
you know obviously i look like 30
seconds
on e-minis other people say that's too
too fast for them they want to look at a
minute
okay sort of start at a starting point
and see
you know is it too volatile is it too
fast for you
you know on a range based chart if
you're
um you know is it covering too much
prices too fast for you
right if you're looking at nasdaq right
you look at nasdaq on a on a
10 range chart before now you can't
right you got it because the bar can
cover
well in a minute you can go
you know 40 points right so maybe you
want to have a 20 range
chart on nasdaq it really depends on the
markets and which e-minis
um what additional software is no
additional software
you need to use my software right you
can you just need ninjatrader again
it'll work on the free version but if
you want to trade through ninjatrader
brokerage
um you're gonna get the paid version
um that way you got lower commissions
and over time it'll pay for itself in
that sense but obviously you got to pay
for your data feed
right because you know you're going to
get the data i get the data from
somewhere
and again if you pay for if you want to
use the free version you can
if you're going to route your orders
through another trading platform
you can use the free version of
ninjatrader but you still have to pay
data fees right because you need
a real-time data feed if you're trading
in real time um
is absorption and exhaustion mike can
you touch on absorption exhaustion after
a significant move
yeah you know basically what i'm looking
after a move
right think of exhaustion
okay markets moving up the last buyer
buys
the market's not going to go any higher
you got no more buying
okay so the market's going to drop just
as
um you want to move down the last seller
sold
who's going to move the market down
nobody there's nobody left to move the
market down
and absorption is kind of the opposite
concept right the market's moving up to
a level
and you got some passive sellers up
there people that are happy to
distribute their supply
right this is a very compact
definition and if the market is
been selling off you got buyers coming
out
you know realizing this is a good deal
and they're going to
you know they're going to be interested
in buying at the low prices
not just at the low of the day but i
mean you know markets don't
well markets don't always go v-shaped
right
you know they they tend to go in more of
a u-shape right they sort of come down
and then go sideways and work their way
back up that's where the absorption is
coming in
i think of an airplane right those
airplanes just don't drop and come in
and land right they come in gradually
slowly going down down down and hit the
runway
that's what markets do is there tech
support if needed yeah there's
there's support most people don't need
it but you know depending on what the
issue is
my programmer is happy to
jump on a call with you and even remote
into your pc to sort things out
um you know sometimes people got a lot
of stuff running on their pc
sometimes they got a lot of an older pc
you know and
you know it's it's rare but it does
happen you know as i say maybe about
three percent of users actually need to
go to
have my programmer jump on with them but
you know it is there it's available for
you
um tony asks now i don't have a live
trading room anymore i just explained
um i might get homeschooling kids but
um not homeschooling but school from
home
because of this covid stuff
um jack asks about uh
he's got the scalper and trader do you
have any special
for turns indicator yeah jack you have
to
shoot me an email you know as a user for
stuff you know
i can you got a couple of my softwares
uh you know um
we could put something together for you
can i use this on forex
yeah chris i asked you a question
already actually um we're gonna make the
software
eaws muhammad
yeah yeah i used to work with emoji a
bit but then he sort of cut me out
of the picture so or whatever
um but yeah it's not available right now
on
on ninjatrader you know we sort of went
in different directions so he cut me out
you know we just went in different
directions that's all
um he's doing his own thing in a
different direction then then i'm going
you know and we left him you know we
broke up i felt like we broke up
on on good terms i like to think you
know it's he
yeah i was happy to help him out when he
got started so
um i like to think we're still on good
terms but
he didn't reply to my last email um when
we've been given permission to directly
connect
we've been given commit permission to
directly connect with
the globex system to test automated
training so it would be kind of cool to
implement
your software directly at the data
center in aurora
martin you have to email me um
directly my email is just you know
people always ask what's your email mike
it's
just mike order flows.com um
is
yeah my email people always ask you know
what's your email what's the best way to
contact you
um i got simple emails just mike at
orderflows.com now granted i do get
a lot of spam emails um and i do get a
lot of emails
every day so i get about 400 you know
when i worked at jp morgan we used to
get
come in every day from the time i go
home at night by the time i come in the
next day because you were copied on it a
lot a lot of garbage
i had to come in i'd have like 300
emails go on vacation for two weeks come
back you'd have like 5 000 emails to
catch up on
and i thought i got past that when i
left but i get a lot of emails so you
know i try to answer them in a timely
manner
and if you know if you're looking for an
answer and i'll give you an answer and
you think a timely manner just shoot me
another email say hey you know i'm just
following up
but that's my email address so martin
email me
um what exactly
then that's about the playbook
yeah you know let me check i'll just
send you an email on the x i know you've
got it
so i'll have to send it to you
um stefan
says he sent me an email about the
upgrade
well stefan i'd say send me an email
again but i'll take a look
okay because like i said you know
sometimes i get a lot of emails and
sometimes stuff goes to spam
but i got your name here i'm gonna check
on it um
after we're done on this but uh i'll
send you the details about
the upgrade um oh you sent those in
october maybe it got lost
can i do it in two payments uh i don't
really offer it in two payments don but
yeah you can email me
and we'll discuss it what tools you use
the most well again it's
there's so many different there's
different markets and i use different
tools in different markets honestly
um you know tools i use the most
now eva there's something
in value areas i really jumped headfirst
into the deep end with with value areas
uh wayne asked about markers with order
flows trader
johnson i haven't set it up i've never
set up overflows trader with markers i
use markers for my other indicators but
not order flows trader
you know there's something i have to
work on and see you know if
if it can or if it could work with
strategy builder
i know my program would know more about
that wayne
but um yeah
that that's something that we'll we'll
dig deeper in
a little further um joe asks about okay
so
s1 charge was that an exhaustion on a 4
000 volume chart um
well let me see
get what you say 4 000 volume um hang on
i don't think i got 4 000 volume here
let me add it here real quick
uh volume volume four thousand
uh okay
okay so do where's my 4000 here
anyways let it come up here while
waiting for that chart to come up um
zw what time chart time frame do i use
for zw
i use a one minute chart
that's wheat no i don't use
pw asks about the ninjatrader volume
metric bars data no it doesn't that's
why we use the tick data
um volumetric you know the there's
you know other software out there is
tied to the volumetric
bars data that's why you need the paid
version my software
runs runs on the free version
of ninjatrader so it doesn't need
the volumetric data
okay so hang on a second here
no no
sorry that was my wife asking me you're
not done yet
um so the free version of
ninjatrader right by software run on
because it reads the the
data that comes in okay whereas if you
need
like there's you know other software
that has a footprint chart
actually relies on the volumetric bars
data so you would need the paid version
okay so there's a slight difference all
right so going back to
exhaustion on a 4 000 um
range chart a 4 000 volume chart okay so
this small print
right right here eight um
two right here right it's seven but
let's move up but really what i'm
looking for
is it coming in at um you know swing
highs or swing lows
you know swing high here you got
divergence
you got a bearish ratio you got the
exhaustion right there
um and again this is set to a level of
nine and below right you know you 4 000
volume
you know maybe you want to set it to 20
or something but honestly setting it
at a low threshold is is probably better
right
look at this swing low right here one
you got that move up okay so
that's what it looks like um
yeah i know a trader that uses guys i
know a trade that uses 10 second charts
yeah you know
when markets were slower actually i was
using five second charts for a while
didn't last very long
but um it uh
in the sense that i was finding myself
in and out of markets too much i said i
i
need to back off and i went to 15
seconds for a while
um but now with this volatility i'm sort
of
one minute is too long for me now the
way this market moves i honestly i
thought when biden got elected i thought
we'd go back to sort of how the market
traded under
obama but uh you know he's only been in
president for what
two months we've already bombed syria
and you know he cut off the keystone
pipeline and obviously jerome powell's
in his own world and
and uh what's her name the woman yelling
these people just speak what are these
people doing on on twitter and
instagram instagram but you know twitter
tweeting about all the stuff and
it's just stay off it you know they
always
complain that you know trump's on
twitter all the time but hey i see
and janet yelling and all these yeah she
just opened an account literally the day
after she got confirmed i think on
twitter
but um yeah you know it's these markets
are quite volatile and i think people
are in for an awakening
this year in the markets one way or
another
um so that comes up there's our alert
setting no don you know for these
different things there are no alerts
settings
um and honestly
for me personally based on my own
experience
dealing with alerts when the market is
moving and going
nuts so to speak and you got all these
alerts going off like sound alerts it
gets confusing and
ultimately you just turn them all off
and you know it's it's just
uh yeah it is
excite i know what it was like you know
i used to have i'd be passed a book
before um you know going back to my days
in the 90s you know actually when we i
left the trading floor and we're trained
upstairs we always had a book you know
we got to deal with
trading book of orders and all this
stuff we always have these levels
you know and programmed into cqg and
bloomberg
and also in the markets would move
you know like a big move and you got
like 20 levels going off and you're
sitting there you're trying to what's
this level going off you know then you
just clear it okay yeah i know about
that when i clear this other one you get
you're hitting because you use that like
the space bar on some of these machines
hit the space bar and
the next thing you know you've missed
something because you had all these
different alerts going off and
that's just me but if you're trading
like my individual indicators have
one have a sound alert right if you're
just trading one market with one
indicator
but on order flow trading a lot of
different things is a bit confusing
but anyway guys um that wraps it up for
today
um i didn't expect i didn't expect it
this went
twice as long as i expected but you know
hopefully by now you
you understand things a lot better about
order flow
and you have something you can come away
with right to help your trading so i'm
going to end it there
so thanks everybody and thanks for your
your patience
and again you know any questions just
shoot me an email
bye bye